Tom's an accountant. And he once said this thing to his kids that really stuck with them because it summed up so much about his personality and how he handles decisions at work and with his family. He said it's his job to assess risk. It was part of his thinking, even when he planned family vacations. Planning vacations would take him months. He'd get travel guides, check out national parks. He'd look for hidden gems near the parks that they could visit along the way. He'd check the local weather.
汤姆是一名会计师。他曾经对他的孩子们说了一番话，这番话深深地印在他们的脑海里，因为它概括了他个性的很多方面，也总结了他如何处理工作和家庭中的决策。他说他的工作就是评估风险。这已经成为了他思维方式的一部分，甚至在他计划家庭度假时也是如此。规划假期通常要花上他好几个月的时间。他会找来旅行指南，研究国家公园。他会寻找公园附近那些他们可以在途中游览的“隐藏瑰宝”。他还会查看当地的天气。
--to make sure that we know what the average temperatures are during those times of years.
——以确保我们了解这些时间段的平均气温。
Now, I'm going to ask this question as an accountant's kid. When you would put together the family's plan for the trip, was that done in an Excel spreadsheet?
现在，我要以一个会计师孩子的身份问这个问题。当你制定家庭旅行计划时，那是用Excel表格完成的吗？
[LAUGHS] You know it. Pretty good, Ira. I like that.
[笑] 你猜对了。干得好，艾拉。我喜欢这个。
And so if I saw that spreadsheet, what would I be seeing?
那么，如果我看到那个表格，我会看到什么呢？
You'd be seeing, from left to right, it has the dates that we're going to-- where we're going to be. And then--
你会看到，从左到右，有我们要去的日期——我们要去的地方。然后——
Also mileage between each spot, number of hours on the road, places to stay, that kind of thing. OK. So one year, the plan was to go to Great Basin National Park in Nevada and hike. And whenever the family would go to a national park, they always liked to do at least one really strenuous and difficult hike as part of the trip. And on this trip, they decided to climb to the top of Wheeler Peak. Tom researched this in advance, of course.
还有每个地点之间的里程、在路上的时间、住宿地点之类的。好的。所以有一年，计划是去内华达州的大盆地国家公园徒步旅行。每次家庭去国家公园时，他们总喜欢在行程中至少安排一次非常剧烈和艰难的徒步活动。在这次旅行中，他们决定爬上惠勒峰的顶端。当然，汤姆提前研究过这个。
And the trail starts 10,000 feet up and you climb 3,000 feet. The one thing that I remember reading was that they said Wheeler is susceptible to changes in weather. So I said, OK. They said, so get out early. So we got out early. We got out at around 7 o'clock in the morning.
步道从海拔10,000英尺处开始，你需要攀爬3,000英尺。我记得读到过的一件事是，他们说惠勒峰的天气容易发生变化。所以我说，好吧。他们说，那就早点出发。所以我们很早就出发了。我们在早上7点左右就动身了。
Of course, he checked the weather forecast for the day.
当然，他查看了当天的天气预报。
And I remember there was a 10% chance of thunderstorms, but later in the afternoon. So I thought, OK, we could get up there by 10 o'clock. We could stay 'til 11:00. Then we could come back down.
我记得预报说有10%的雷阵雨概率，但那是在下午晚些时候。所以我想，好吧，我们可以在10点钟到达山顶。我们可以待到11点。然后我们就可以回来了。
And avoid the trouble.
从而避开麻烦。
Correct. And so the best laid plans, as we later found out--
没错。正如我们后来发现的那样，计划赶不上变化——
We headed out on time. It was a beautiful day, probably about in the 70s, nice little breeze.
我们按时出发了。那是一个美好的一天，气温大概在70多华氏度（约21-26摄氏度），微风阵阵。
His two kids-- Mark, who was 20. Angela, who was 18-- sped ahead up the trail as usual. Tom and his wife, Marion, weren't that far behind. And they're going up the switchbacks, just a lovely, perfect day-- until the two kids get hit by lightning.
他的两个孩子——20岁的马克和18岁的安吉拉——像往常一样在步道上飞奔在前。汤姆和他的妻子马里昂离他们不远。他们正沿着之字形小路向上走，本来是完美的一天——直到两个孩子被闪电击中。
I don't remember seeing a bolt. I just remember seeing everything flash white.
我不记得看到了闪电。我只记得看到周围一切都闪烁着白光。
This, of course, is Angela. And I learned this family's story from her when she worked here at our radio show. Basically, she and her brother got to the top of the mountain before their parents. Dark clouds rolled in really fast. Within minutes, it was hailing, the temperature dropped, and there was lightning. The strike which hit Angela and Mark wasn't a direct hit. It probably hit some boulders next to them.
当然，这是安吉拉。我是从她那里了解到这个家庭的故事的，当时她在我们的广播节目工作。基本上，她和她哥哥在父母之前到达了山顶。乌云迅速聚拢。几分钟内，就开始下冰雹，气温骤降，而且出现了闪电。击中安吉拉和马克的闪电并非直接命中。它可能击中了他们旁边的几块巨石。
What I felt was as if somebody took a bottle and slammed it onto my head. I remember my arms flying up, as though I was a puppet and somebody draws the string. And we were knocked down. I remember falling on my butt. And my brother, he describes it as getting tackled, just this feeling of being physically overcome, rather than an electric current running through your body. And we were just freaking out. We were like, what the hell just happened? Screaming, screaming, cursing, cursing.
我的感觉就像有人拿着瓶子猛击我的头。我记得我的手臂飞了起来，就像我是个木偶，有人拉动了绳子。我们被撞倒了。我记得我摔在了屁股上。我哥哥形容那感觉像是被擒抱，是一种被物理力量击倒的感觉，而不是电流流过身体的感觉。我们当时都吓坏了。我们就在喊，到底发生了什么？尖叫着、咒骂着。
They run down the mountain towards their parents, who were just a little ways down the mountain, crouched like turtles low in some shrubs so they don't get struck by lightning, getting pelted by hail. They have no idea this has happened to their kids.
他们跑下山，向他们的父母冲去。父母就在山下不远处，像乌龟一样蜷缩在灌木丛中，以免被闪电击中，同时还在承受冰雹的袭击。他们根本不知道孩子们遭遇了什么。
And Mark and Angela, we were waiting for them to come down. And we're worried, as we could see the lightning striking. And you could see it almost sizzle as it hits the mountain. And we finally see them coming down the mountain. And I could see the lightning hitting the mountainside really close to where they are. And I'm thinking, oh, my god. My kids are going to get killed. And that's when I thought, what a mistake I made here. I never planned for this.
马克和安吉拉跑下来时，我们在等他们。我们很担心，因为我们能看到闪电。你几乎可以看到闪电击中山体时发出的咝咝声。终于，我们看到他们跑下山来。我能看到闪电击中离他们很近的山坡。我心想，天哪，我的孩子们要没命了。就在那时，我想，我犯了多大的错啊。我从来没计划过这种情况。
Finally, the kids reach them.
终于，孩子们赶到了他们身边。
And Marion, says, thank God you didn't get hit by lightning. And Angela said, yeah, well, we did.
马里昂说，谢天谢地，你们没被闪电击中。安吉拉说，是啊，不过我们确实被击中了。
The kids were shaken up, sore, but no serious injuries.
孩子们受到了惊吓，身体疼痛，但没有受重伤。
I don't think I was particularly traumatized.
我觉得我并没有留下什么心理创伤。
Wow. You got hit by lightning.
哇。你被闪电击中了。
I get traumatized by people who are mean to me. Lightning's not personal. You know what I mean? The lightning wasn't like, Angela, you're ugly. The lightning was just doing its thing.
我是被那些对我刻薄的人伤害才会感到创伤的。闪电不是针对个人的。你懂我的意思吗？闪电并不是说“安吉拉，你很丑”。闪电只是在做它自己的事。
Tom, meanwhile, felt two conflicting feelings. On the one hand, he'd taken precautions. He'd checked the weather. He had a spreadsheet. He knew he had planned as well as he could. But at the same time, he felt a lot of guilt for putting the kids in that situation.
与此同时，汤姆感受到了两种矛盾的情绪。一方面，他采取了预防措施。他查了天气，有表格。他知道自己已经尽力做了最好的计划。但与此同时，他因为让孩子们处于那种境地而感到深深的内疚。
Yeah, I felt very badly about that. And for the next couple of weeks, I would wake up at night, thinking about what I saw and what happened and the peril I put everybody in.
是的，我对此感到非常糟糕。在接下来的几周里，我会在夜里惊醒，想到我所看到的、发生的事情，以及我让大家陷入的危险。
After this trip, he said, any day he took the family out for a hike--
在那次旅行之后，他说，任何一天他带家人去远足——
I would make sure that, weather-wise, we were pretty much in the clear. Although, like I said, we were pretty much in the clear for this day too.
我都会确保在天气方面，我们基本上是安全的。尽管就像我说的，那天我们也基本上是安全的。
Yeah, how could you be more in the clear than you were that day? You were in the clear. It was 10% chance of rain in the afternoon. It doesn't barely get better than that. That's pretty good.
是啊，怎么可能比那天更安全呢？你们当时确实很安全。下午只有10%的降雨概率。几乎没有比这更好的情况了。那已经很不错了。
Yeah. And I think the other thing is, when you're on a vacation and you know you're not coming back to this place anytime soon or ever again, well, I guess you might roll the dice a little bit more.
是的。而且我认为另一件事是，当你在度假，你知道你以后可能不会再回到这个地方，或者永远不会再回来，嗯，我想你可能会多冒一点险。
I know, but you weren't rolling the dice. You had 10% chance of precipitation. It's funny. I feel like, listening to you talk about this, you do seem like you feel like you could have done something. But it really doesn't seem like there's anything you could have done.
我知道，但你当时并没有冒险。你当时降水的概率只有10%。真好笑。我觉得，听你谈论这件事，你似乎觉得自己本可以做点什么。但看起来确实没什么你能做的。
That's my Catholic education.
那是我的天主教教育在作祟。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
You got to be guilty about something, right? The Italian Catholic education, you got to be guilty about something.
你总得对什么事情感到内疚，对吧？意大利天主教教育，你总得对什么事情感到内疚。
OK. So with respect to everybody's religious education right now, ladies and gentlemen, sometimes you make a plan, and random stuff happens that you really could not have anticipated. Today on our program, we have stories of people making very reasonable, very sound plans that emphatically do not work out for them. As somebody once said, no one expects the Spanish Inquisition. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好的。所以，考虑到大家的宗教教育，女士们先生们，有时你制定了计划，但会发生一些你确实无法预料的随机事件。今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲的是人们做出非常合理、非常稳健的计划，但最终却未能实现的故事。正如某人所说，没人预料得到西班牙宗教裁判所。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
This American Life, Act One, Forces Outside Our Control. April was going to be their month-- I mean the April that just passed, a couple of months ago. This couple had been waiting years for this. They'd been long distance for an insanely long time, six years. Then they both moved to New York, got married. But he was in school. Now, finally, he was out.
《美国生活》，第一幕，我们无法控制的力量。四月本该是属于他们的月份——我是指刚过去的四月，几个月前。这对夫妇已经为此等待多年。他们经历了一段异常漫长的异地恋，整整六年。后来他们都搬到了纽约，结了婚。但他还在上学。现在，他终于毕业了。
And they were at that moment as a young couple, when you're excited for your life to really kick in. She was pregnant, working full time as a dentist, just three weeks away from maternity leave. He had finished grad school in December. She was 28. He was 30. Noor and Mahmoud-- our story begins in March.
他们正处于一对年轻夫妇最期待生活真正开始的时刻。她怀孕了，作为牙医全职工作，离产假还有三周。他在十二月完成了研究生学业。她28岁，他30岁。努尔和马哈茂德——我们的故事从三月开始。
It was a transitional phase, for sure. Mahmoud had just got a job offer, so he was going to start his job. And it was kind of like a transition from-- because when Mahmoud was in school, I was the one who was working.
那确实是一个过渡阶段。马哈茂德刚拿到工作机会，所以他即将开始工作。这就像是一种过渡——因为当马哈茂德在读书时，是我在工作。
You're supporting the two of you.
你在支持你们两个人。
Exactly.
没错。
And Noor would go to work. So I would do all the house stuff. I would cook. Noor would come, like, at 6:00, 7:00. We would eat dinner and just, like, Reba.
努尔会去上班。所以我负责所有家务。我做饭。努尔会在6点、7点左右回来。我们会一起吃晚饭，然后看《瑞芭》。
Watch Reba. [LAUGHS]
看《瑞芭》。[笑]
You know, Reba, the sitcom from the early 2000s with country music star, Reba McEntire. I know, very random.
你知道的，《瑞芭》，那部21世纪初的情景喜剧，由乡村音乐明星瑞芭·麦肯泰尔主演。我知道，这很随机。
Yeah, Reba was the show we were watching. No, like an easy, lighthearted, fun show.
是的，《瑞芭》是我们当时看的节目。不是那种，它是一个轻松、有趣、让人心情愉快的剧。
Wait, and were you making him watch it?
等等，是你让他陪你看的吗？
Basically. [LAUGHS] I choose the Netflix shows that we are going to watch, so yeah. But you liked it.
基本上是。[笑] 我负责挑选我们要看的Netflix节目，所以是的。但你也喜欢它。
I mean, it's a background show so-- no, no, I mean--
我的意思是，它是个背景剧，所以——不，不，我的意思是——
OK, I'm kind of slow playing an important fact about these two people, and maybe it's time to be less coy about that. Mahmoud is Mahmoud Khalil. And the thing that had interrupted the plan for April is something you might have heard of. In March, he became the test case, the pioneer, the very first student protester that the Trump administration detained and tried to deport because of his participation in student protests. There was a video that Noor filmed of officers arresting him in the lobby of the student housing. Maybe you saw this. He's standing by the mailboxes when they put handcuffs on him.
好吧，关于这两个人，我可能隐瞒了一个重要的事实，现在是时候不再遮遮掩掩了。马哈茂德是马哈茂德·哈利勒。而那件打断了四月计划的事情，你们可能听说过。三月，他成为了特朗普政府拘留并试图驱逐出境的第一个典型案例，第一位学生抗议者，原因是他参与了学生抗议活动。努尔拍下了一段视频，显示官员在学生公寓的大厅逮捕了他。也许你看到过。他们给他戴上手铐时，他正站在邮箱旁。
That's not--
这不对——
Stop resisting.
停止反抗。
OK, OK. He's not resisting. He's giving me his phone, OK? He's not-- I understand.
好的，好的。他没有反抗。他在给我手机，好吗？他没有——我明白。
Turn around.
转过去。
He's not resisting.
他没有反抗。
Put your arms--
把你的手臂——
You guys really don't need to be doing all of that.
你们真的没必要做这种事。
Put your arms--
把你的手臂——
In the video, Mahmoud's back is to the camera. And he looks back towards Noor to comfort her, even though he's the one being arrested.
在视频中，马哈茂德背对着镜头。尽管他才是被逮捕的那个人，他还是回头看向努尔安慰她。
It's fine. It's fine. Habibi, it's fine. Come on.
没事的。没事的。亲爱的（Habibi），没事的。走吧。
He says, it's fine. It's fine. Habibi, it's fine.
他说，没事的。没事的。亲爱的，没事的。
OK.
好的。
Noor gets on the phone with a lawyer.
努尔给律师打了电话。
Hi, Amy. Yeah. They just handcuffed him and took him. I don't know what to do. And what should I do? I don't know.
嗨，艾米。是的。他们刚给他戴上手铐把他带走了。我不知道该怎么办。我该做什么？我不知道。
The video got a lot of attention, partly because it was the first video of a student arrested like this-- plainclothes officers, without a warrant, putting him into an unmarked vehicle, not answering basic questions.
这段视频引起了广泛关注，部分原因是这是首个此类被捕学生的视频——便衣警察，没有搜查令，将他塞进一辆无标记车辆，且不回答基本问题。
Can we get a name, please, of-- Can we get your name? I understand. The lawyer is asking for your name.
能告诉我们你的名字吗，请——能告诉我们你的名字吗？我明白。律师在问你的名字。
Get back please. Over there.
后退，请。到那边去。
We don't give our names.
我们不提供我们的名字。
He's saying they don't give their names.
他说他们不提供名字。
Mahmoud later said it felt like a kidnapping. Part of what was so shocking about it at the time was the fact that Mahmoud Khalil was not here on a student visa or some kind of temporary status. He's a permanent legal resident with a green card, married to a US citizen with a baby on the way, not the kind of person we thought of as a candidate for deportation at the time, long, long ago, back in March.
马哈茂德后来形容那感觉就像被绑架了。当时之所以如此令人震惊，是因为马哈茂德·哈利勒并不是持学生签证或某种临时身份在这里。他是持有绿卡的永久合法居民，与美国公民结婚，而且孩子即将出生，他不是我们当时认为会被驱逐出境的那种人，那是在很久很久以前，三月份的时候。
Since then, the government has attempted to revoke or terminate the visas of over 6,000 students. And Mahmoud Khalil became a symbol, exhibit A for the aggressive new tactics that the administration is using to crack down on dissent. His case will help determine whether the president and secretary of state have the power to kick somebody out of the country for protesting, or anything else they think runs counter to the policy goals of the United States.
从那以后，政府试图撤销或终止超过6,000名学生的签证。而马哈茂德·哈利勒成为了一个象征，成为了政府打击异议的激进新策略的典型案例。他的案子将有助于决定总统和国务卿是否有权因为某人抗议，或因为他们认为违背美国政策目标的任何其他原因，而将某人驱逐出境。
Here at our show, we started working on a story about Mahmoud back in March, in the early days when he was still in detention. At the time, some of the most powerful people in the country-- the president and the Speaker of the House-- were calling him an aspiring young terrorist and a mastermind of student violence, a radical, foreign pro-Hamas student. It was all so cartoonish. It made me wonder what the reality was. Who was this man-- Mahmoud Khalil?
在我们的节目中，我们早在三月就开始关注马哈茂德的故事，当时他还处于拘留中。那时，一些国家最有权势的人——总统和众议院议长——称他为雄心勃勃的年轻恐怖分子，称他是学生暴力活动的策划者，一个激进的、外国哈马斯学生。这一切都太卡通化了。这让我怀疑事实究竟是什么。这个男人——马哈茂德·哈利勒究竟是谁？
And to figure that out, I teamed up with a reporter, Suzanne Gaber, who covered the Columbia protests and travels in some of the same circles as Mahmoud Khalil and his wife. And we interviewed people around Mahmoud Khalil who know him, who described him as a very particular kind of person, somebody who asks a lot of questions, someone who chooses his words with a lot of care. But while he was in detention, the government stopped us and other reporters from interviewing him. He came out in June and we talked to him, finally.
为了弄清楚这一点，我和记者苏珊·盖伯合作，她报道了哥伦比亚大学的抗议活动，并且和马哈茂德·哈利勒夫妇在同一个圈子里活动。我们采访了马哈茂德·哈利勒周围认识他的人，他们把他描述为一个非常独特的人，一个喜欢问很多问题的人，一个对言辞非常谨慎的人。但在他被拘留期间，政府阻止了我们和其他记者采访他。他在六月获释，我们终于和他谈了谈。
The Trump administration and rightwing media were still describing him as a menace to society. On the left, he was seen as kind of a folk hero. But not a lot has been written about who he really is or what it's been like for him to live through this from day to day-- his arrest, his detention, his new international notoriety. And I'm going to bring Suzanne Gaber on now to present this story with me from this point forward. Hey there, Suze.
特朗普政府和右翼媒体仍然把他描述为社会的威胁。在左翼看来，他成了某种民间英雄。但关于他究竟是谁，或者他每天如何度过这段时光——他的被捕、拘留、他带来的国际恶名——并没有多少报道。现在我要请苏珊·盖伯和我一起从这一点开始呈现这个故事。你好，苏兹。
Hey. So yeah, like you said, before the arrest, Mahmoud and Noor were at this turning point in their lives that they'd been planning for years. And specifically, they were focused on two dates coming up in April, just weeks away-- the due date for the new baby, and Mahmoud was about to start a new job, his first job after grad school.
嘿。是的，就像你说的，在逮捕之前，马哈茂德和努尔正处于他们多年来一直规划的人生转折点。具体来说，他们专注于四月份即将到来的两个日期，仅剩几周时间——新宝宝的预产期，以及马哈茂德即将开始的一份新工作，这是他研究生毕业后的第一份工作。
And that moment, before all this happened-- one of their friends described it nicely to us. Her name's Jasmine Sarryeh. Mahmoud and Nour suggested we talk to her. She started as Mahmoud's friend. They're both Palestinian. They were at Columbia grad school together. But then she got close to Noor too. She was the witness at their wedding. Jasmine and Mahmoud were both involved in the Columbia student protests against the war in Gaza. And Jasmine pointed out that in the months before Mahmoud's arrest, he was winding down his student activism.
在那一切发生之前，他们的一个朋友很好地向我们描述了那一刻。她的名字是茉莉·萨里耶。马哈茂德和努尔建议我们找她谈谈。她最初是马哈茂德的朋友。他们都是巴勒斯坦人。他们一起在哥伦比亚大学读研。后来她也和努尔亲近起来。她是他们婚礼上的证人。茉莉和马哈茂德都参与了哥伦比亚大学反对加沙战争的学生抗议活动。茉莉指出，在马哈茂德被捕前的几个月里，他正在逐步退出学生运动。
And I think me and Noor were sort of like, OK, now that Mahmoud's graduated, I was like, oh, Mahmoud's finally going to step into the real world and see what it's-- the crushing blow of having to work 9:00 to 5:00 and not-- so sometimes she would say things like-- like any wife would. And I don't want to make her seem like she's not supportive, because she is. But like, you need to be more present here.
我想我和努尔当时都觉得，好吧，现在马哈茂德毕业了，我觉得，哦，马哈茂德终于要步入现实世界，看看什么是——不得不朝九晚五工作的沉重打击，而不是——所以有时她会说一些话——就像任何妻子那样。我不想让她看起来好像不支持他，因为她是支持的。但就像是，你需要在这里表现得更专注。
And he was. He really was at the end. We were talking about apartment hunting. And we were going to throw her a baby shower. And he was always talking baby stuff after he graduated.
他确实是。最后他确实做到了。我们在谈论寻找公寓。我们本来要给她举办迎婴派对。他毕业后总是在谈论孩子的事情。
When it comes to getting these big, lifechanging plans in motion, Noor and Mahmoud seemed like they have a pretty equal partnership. They both say she's the worrier. He's the calm one. She's the organized one. And he's nonchalant, as he puts it.
在执行这些改变人生的宏大计划时，努尔和马哈茂德看起来是一对非常平等的伴侣。他们都说她是那个担心的人。他是那个冷静的人。她是那个有组织的人。而他，用他的话说，是那种漫不经心的人。
Do you want to tell them how you procrastinated your British embassy application? [LAUGHS] Let me tell you that story.
你想告诉他们你是怎么拖延英国大使馆申请的吗？[笑] 让我来讲那个故事。
What she's talking about here is something that happened years ago, when he was living in Lebanon and he applied for a job. This is before he came to America. And this turns out to be one of those stories that all couples have, where one partner tells it to prove a perhaps unflattering point about the other partner. And the way this came up is that, in our interview, Mahmoud mentioned in passing that he procrastinates sometimes. And that's when Noor busted out with--
她说的是多年前发生的一件事，当时他住在黎巴嫩，申请了一份工作。那是他来美国之前的事。结果这成了所有夫妇都会有的那种故事，其中一方讲述它是为了证明关于另一方可能不讨人喜欢的观点。这件事之所以被提出来，是因为在采访中，马哈茂德顺便提到他有时会拖延。就在那时，努尔突然说——
Let me tell you that story. He saw this job, and he was like. I need to apply. And he kept procrastinating and procrastinating and procrastinating. And then--
让我来讲那个故事。他看到了这份工作，然后他说。我需要申请。他不断地拖延，拖延，又拖延。然后——
Noor freaks out. And that--
努尔吓坏了。那——
I do, yeah.
我是，是的。
--also irritates me.
——也惹恼了我。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Just let me be.
让我待着就行。
Yes. And then it came to the day where he was supposed to put in the application, and he missed the deadline.
是的。然后到了他应该提交申请的那一天，他错过了截止日期。
It was their fault, though.
不过那是他们的错。
OK. Please tell me how it's their fault.
好吧。请告诉我怎么就是他们的错了。
What's usually the deadline? It's, like, 11:59. For that specific job, it was 11:55. So I go to click Submit, like, 11:57. And then they say, oh, you missed the deadline. And I was like--
截止日期通常是什么时候？大概是11:59。对于那份特定工作，是11:55。所以我去点击提交，大概是11:57。然后他们说，哦，你错过了截止日期。然后我就——
And of course, I was like, I told you. Apply earlier.
当然，我说，我告诉过你了。早点申请。
In the end, they extended the deadline for everybody. He got the job and worked at it for four years.
最后，他们为所有人延长了截止日期。他得到了那份工作，并在那里工作了四年。
So it's March of this year. They're on the cusp of this new life. And Mahmoud gets detained on March 8. ICE officers flew him from New York to Louisiana. He ended up 1,400 miles away in a facility in a remote town called Jena. He lived in a big room with 70 ICE detainees, bunk beds, three urinals, three toilets in that same room, no privacy, lights always on. Noor sent Jasmine to visit him because she was too pregnant to go herself.
所以是今年三月。他们站在新生活的门槛上。马哈茂德在3月8日被拘留。移民和海关执法局（ICE）的官员把他从纽约飞往路易斯安那州。他最终被关在1,400英里外一个偏远小镇杰纳的设施里。他住在一个大房间里，里面有70名ICE拘留者，上下铺，三个小便池，三个马桶在同一个房间，没有隐私，灯始终亮着。努尔派茉莉去探望他，因为她怀孕了不能亲自去。
He probably wasn't being fully honest with her, which I think anyone wouldn't be, right? You'd want to say, like, oh, I'm fine. I'm fine. When I went to see him in Louisiana, I was so worried because he was telling me he wasn't eating. And he was saying he was really cold and he wasn't sleeping. Mahmoud's always put together. You can see lots of pictures of him in suits. And his hair was a mess. And his skin was kind of peeling. And I knew that he has a special shampoo and eczema lotion that he uses on his face. And he just looked different.
他可能没有对她完全诚实，我想没人会吧，对吧？你会想说，哦，我很好。我很好。当我去路易斯安那州看他时，我非常担心，因为他告诉我他没吃东西。他说他非常冷，也没睡觉。马哈茂德总是打理得很好。你可以看到很多他穿着西装的照片。而他的头发乱糟糟的。他的皮肤有点在脱皮。我知道他有专门使用的洗发水和脸部湿疹乳液。他看起来就是不一样了。
When Mahmoud describes his time, it's nowhere as dark. He was able to call Noor. He talked a lot to his lawyers, helped other prisoners with their paperwork and cases. And everybody around him says that he was always optimistic about his case. He believed he hadn't done anything wrong. And he trusted that the US is a place with rules and laws. That was definitely not true where he grew up. His childhood was in a refugee camp in Syria, where, as a teenager, he'd protested the regime of Bashar al-Assad. Two friends of his were disappeared. At those protests--
当马哈茂德描述他的时光时，情况并不那么黑暗。他能够给努尔打电话。他经常与律师交谈，帮助其他囚犯处理文件和案件。他周围的每个人都说，他对自己的案子一直保持乐观。他认为自己没做错任何事。他相信美国是一个有规则和法律的地方。这在他成长的地方绝对不是真的。他的童年是在叙利亚的一个难民营里度过的，十几岁时，他抗议过巴沙尔·阿萨德的政权。他的两个朋友失踪了。在那些抗议活动中——
It's not that the police would come and arrest you. It's that the police would come and kill you. That was the stakes. So you're literally walking to your death in these demonstrations.
并不是说警察会来逮捕你。而是警察会来杀你。赌注就是这样。所以你在这些示威中实际上是走向死亡。
Do you think that you were so calm when you saw that the White House was tweeting about you because it had been so much more dangerous for you, doing activism in Syria when you were young?
你认为当你看到白宫在推特上提到你时，你表现得那么冷静，是因为你在年轻时在叙利亚进行激进活动时经历过更危险的事情吗？
I haven't thought about it. But my early years, growing up in the refugee camp, literally living under bombardments for an extended period of time, that whole experience, I think, made me more-- I wouldn't call it resilient. It's just--
我没想过这个问题。但我早年是在难民营长大的，在很长一段时间里实际上是在轰炸下生活，我想，整个经历让我变得更——我不会称之为韧性。这只是——
But it is resilient. That is--
但这确实是韧性。那是——
Yeah. I mean, yeah. It's not a very healthy resilience, I know.
是的。我是说，是的。这不是一种健康的韧性，我知道。
It's hard to imagine now. But when he was first detained, Mahmoud still thought maybe this wouldn't be a huge disruption. They'd get their lives back and he'd be out in time for those two dates in April, the start of his new job and the baby's due date.
现在很难想象了。但当他最初被拘留时，马哈茂德仍然认为这可能不会是一个巨大的干扰。他们会找回他们的生活，他会及时赶上四月份的两个日期，新工作的开始和宝宝的预产期。
The job was with Oxfam, the humanitarian aid group, doing policy at the United Nations, focusing specifically on the Middle East and the Palestinian territories. It was exactly the kind of job he'd been working towards for years. He'd worked in Lebanon for a group that ran schools for refugees, taught himself English, did similar work for refugees at the British embassy, and then got himself into Columbia University's School of International and Public Affairs.
那份工作是与乐施会（Oxfam）合作，这是一个人道主义援助组织，在联合国从事政策工作，专门关注中东和巴勒斯坦领土。这正是他多年来一直为之努力的工作。他在黎巴嫩为一所难民学校工作过，自学英语，在英国大使馆为难民做类似的工作，然后进入了哥伦比亚大学国际与公共事务学院。
The start date was coming up, April 1. And when he was arrested, it probably would have been good employee etiquette to contact his future bosses at Oxfam, but he figured that they had heard. He and Noor talked all the time on the phone when he was in detention. And she had access to his email. And he would ask her, did they email? Did they email? Remember, baby on the way-- they were anxious to become a two-income household. They heard nothing. His start date came and went. And two days later, an email arrived, rescinding the job offer.
开始日期是4月1日。当他被捕时，联系他在乐施会的未来老板可能是员工礼仪，但他认为他们已经听说了。他在拘留期间一直和努尔通过电话交谈。她可以访问他的邮箱。他会问她，他们发邮件了吗？他们发邮件了吗？记住，孩子快出生了——他们急于成为双职工家庭。他们什么都没听到。他的入职日期过去了。两天后，一封邮件到了，解除了工作录用。
Noor read me the email. That was very, very disappointing.
努尔给我读了那封邮件。那非常非常令人失望。
Mahmoud and Noor assume that if he hadn't been arrested by the Trump administration, he would still have the job, that it would be hard for Oxfam or for any group doing development work to hire somebody that the White House named as a terrorist sympathizer. Oxfam declined our request for an interview about this. It was April 3 that Mahmoud heard he lost the job. The baby was due April 28.
马哈茂德和努尔认为，如果他没有被特朗普政府逮捕，他现在还会保留那份工作，乐施会或任何从事发展工作的组织很难雇用一个被白宫点名为恐怖分子同情者的人。乐施会拒绝了我们关于此事的采访请求。4月3日，马哈茂德得知他丢了工作。宝宝预产期是4月28日。
Noor told me that she had a deep fear about giving birth alone. And everyone kept telling her, don't worry. Don't worry. Your first baby is usually late. Mahmoud will be out by then. Then she went into labor a week early, April 20. Immediately, she called Mahmoud's lawyers. It's happening. Try and get him out. They asked for an emergency furlough, which prisons sometimes give in urgent family situations like this. They hoped Mahmoud could fly to New York for just the birth with an ankle monitor and check-ins with the government. They were denied in less than an hour. And they ended up in this situation that they both feared-- Noor in a hospital room without him.
努尔告诉我，她非常害怕独自生产。每个人都一直告诉她，别担心。别担心。第一个孩子通常会晚出生。马哈茂德到那时会出来的。然后她提前一周在4月20日临盆了。她立即打电话给马哈茂德的律师。事情发生了。试着让他出来。他们申请了紧急休假，监狱有时会在这种紧急家庭情况下给予这种假期。他们希望马哈茂德能戴着电子脚镣，定期向政府报备，赶到纽约参加生产。他们在一小时内就被拒绝了。最终，他们陷入了两人都害怕的情况——努尔在产房里，没有他。
He was on the phone, yes, which also, my doctor afterwards-- she's like, every time I saw you talking on the phone, I got so sad. [LAUGHS] Yeah. He was on the phone, giving moral support as much as he could. I put headphones in and then-- yeah, the headphones were in my ear.
他是在电话里，是的，后来我的医生说，每次看到你在打电话，我都觉得好难过。[笑] 是的。他在电话里，尽他所能给予精神支持。我戴上耳机，然后——是的，耳机就在我的耳朵里。
It was 4:00 AM. Mahmoud's crouched on the floor in Louisiana. He's in a room with 70 detainees, and most of them were asleep. So he whispered over the phone.
当时是凌晨4点。马哈茂德在路易斯安那州的地上蜷缩着。他和70名被拘留者住在一起，他们大多在睡觉。所以他在电话里低语。
And to me, it's just like, to me was just trying to really picture the room, Noor. Is she fine? Because it was like a one-way call. No one is answering me. Even when I talk to her, I don't know if she can hear it because she's in labor. So it felt like talking to the void. But I still would speak supporting words to Noor.
对我来说，就像是，我想在脑海里勾勒出那个房间，努尔。她还好吗？因为那是个单向通话。没人回答我。即使我跟她说话，我也不知道她能不能听见，因为她在临盆。所以感觉就像是对着虚空说话。但我仍然会对努尔说支持的话。
He was trying as best as he could, just support, like, oh, you're doing good.
他尽他所能，给予支持，比如，哦，你做得很好。
You know, it's happening, habibti, just a little bit more, a little bit more.
你知道的，这正在发生，亲爱的（Habibti），再坚持一点，再一点。
At one point, my headphones fell out, so I wasn't hearing him anymore. And obviously, you're pushing. You're in labor. I'm not thinking about, oh, let me put the headphones back in. But my mom ended up taking the phone. And he was like, oh, put her on the phone. And my mom's trying to give me the phone so I can listen. And I was like, no. I'm dying at this point.
有一次，我的耳机掉了，所以我再也听不到他说话了。显然，你在用力。你在生孩子。我没想过，哦，让我把耳机戴回去。但我妈最终拿过了电话。他说，哦，让她接电话。我妈试图把电话递给我，这样我就能听。我当时说，不。我快死了。
Her mom put the phone close enough to her ear so that she could hear him. Every 45 minutes, the phone line would cut out because the detention center limits the length of phone calls. So he'd call back, hoping they would answer.
她妈把电话凑到她耳边，让她能听到他的声音。每45分钟，电话线路就会中断，因为拘留中心限制通话时长。所以他会打回去，希望他们接听。
A couple of times, they did not answer me, because they forgot the phone-- it was on the side-- until they saw that, actually, it was hung up and now I'm calling again.
有几次，他们没有回答我，因为他们忘了电话——它在旁边——直到他们发现，实际上它已经挂断了，现在我正在再次拨打。
When the baby was finally born, a boy they named Deen, they took the phone and put it to his ear. In Muslim families, the father will often recite the adhan, the call to prayer, right after the baby is born, welcoming them into the world. Mahmoud had thought about that moment a lot.
当孩子最终出生时，一个他们取名为迪恩（Deen）的男孩，他们拿过电话，贴在他的耳边。在穆斯林家庭中，父亲通常会在孩子出生后宣礼（Adhan），即召唤祷告，欢迎他们来到这个世界。马哈茂德曾多次想到那一刻。
I can't describe it, how important, that to me. More than religiously, it's culturally, to have the father to call the adhan. It's just my first time for him to hear my voice. But that was really difficult. My voice would crack while I'm reciting in Deen's ear.
我无法形容，那对我来说有多重要。与其说是宗教，不如说是文化，作为父亲去宣礼。这是他第一次听到我的声音。但这真的很困难。我在迪恩耳边诵读时，声音在颤抖。
Yeah, I can't imagine. Was that the most emotional you'd been in detention?
是的，我无法想象。那是你在拘留期间情绪最激动的时候吗？
I believe so. I don't think there's words to describe it. The fact that we literally dreamed about this moment for so long-- it just felt very cruel that this happened to us, to have this moment stolen.
我想是吧。我不认为有什么词可以形容它。我们为这一刻梦想了这么久，这一事实——这感觉非常残酷，我们竟然遇到了这种事，拥有这一刻被偷走了。
Two days later, Noor's mom and sister took her home from the hospital. They went to park the car. She took Deen upstairs.
两天后，努尔的妈妈和姐姐把她从医院接回家。她们去停车。她把迪恩抱上楼。
So when I first came into the apartment, I was by myself, very quiet. And I put him down in his car seat, just on the kitchen floor. And we got home around sunset. And the sunset was beautiful. It was like this-- I mean, you can see my apartment. There's a lot of sun that comes in. And it was just shining into our apartment. I had this beautiful baby. And then it was just quiet in the apartment. Mahmoud was not there.
所以当我第一次进入公寓时，我是一个人，非常安静。我把他放下在婴儿座椅上，就在厨房的地板上。我们日落时分回到了家。日落很美。就像是这个——我是说，你可以看到我的公寓。阳光照进来很多。它就照在我们的公寓里。我有一个美丽的宝宝。然后公寓里就静悄悄的。马哈茂德不在那里。
And that's when it hit me. And then I just started crying. And I'm just looking at Deen in his car seat. He was sleeping so peacefully. I was upset. I was so mad. It was not the way I had imagined, and it was not the way that we had talked about. So it was a very frustrating day, I think.
就在那时，我深受触动。我开始哭。我看着婴儿座椅里的迪恩。他睡得那么安详。我很难过。我非常生气。这不是我所想象的方式，也不是我们谈论过的方式。所以我想，那是一个非常沮丧的一天。
So April 3, Mahmoud didn't get the new job. April 21, the baby came, and he wasn't there. He was still in detention. And it wasn't clear when or if he'd get out.
所以4月3日，马哈茂德没得到新工作。4月21日，宝宝出生了，他不在那里。他仍然在拘留中。而且不清楚他什么时候能出来，或者能否出来。
This is as good a spot as any to talk about the charges that were keeping Mahmoud in detention and upending his life and to talk about the stakes of this case for the whole country. Traditionally, of course, the kind of thing that Mahmoud did-- he was part of student protests-- would have been seen as being protected by the Constitution. It's part of our right to free speech. But the argument that the administration is making in court is that the secretary of state has the power to decide if somebody's presence in the United States undermines US foreign policy and then kick them out of the country. This is based on an immigration law enacted at the height of McCarthyism in the 1950s.
这是一个谈论将马哈茂德关在拘留中并颠覆他生活，以及讨论此案对整个国家利害关系的绝佳地点。传统上，马哈茂德所做的事情——他参与了学生抗议活动——本来会被视为受到宪法保护。这是我们言论自由权的一部分。但政府在法庭上提出的论点是，国务卿有权决定某人在美国的存在是否破坏了美国的外交政策，然后将他们驱逐出境。这基于20世纪50年代麦卡锡主义高潮时期制定的移民法。
And the things that the administration believes that Mahmoud Khalil has done that merit getting kicked out of the country, that would override his right to free speech, those things actually are not spelled out in the government's filings in the case. But when White House Press Secretary Karoline Leavitt tried to explain how Mahmoud undermines US policy at a press conference, she said, Mahmoud first came here to study.
而政府认为马哈茂德·哈利勒做了什么值得被驱逐出境，从而凌驾于他的言论自由权之上的事情，这些事情实际上在政府的案件文件中并没有详细说明。但当白宫新闻秘书卡罗琳·莱维特在新闻发布会上试图解释马哈茂德如何破坏美国政策时，她说，马哈茂德最初是来学习的。
And he took advantage of that opportunity, of that privilege, by siding with terrorists, Hamas terrorists who have killed innocent men, women, and children. This is an individual who organized group protests that not only disrupted college campus classes and harassed Jewish-American students and made them feel unsafe, but also distributed pro-Hamas propaganda, flyers with the logo of Hamas. That is what the behavior and activity that this individual engaged in. That's what this individual distributed on the campus of Columbia University.
他利用了那个机会，那个特权，站在了恐怖分子一边，那些杀害无辜男女老少的哈马斯恐怖分子一边。这是一个组织了小组抗议活动的人，这些抗议不仅扰乱了大学课堂，骚扰了美籍犹太学生，让他们感到不安全，还分发亲哈马斯宣传品，分发带有哈马斯标志的传单。这就是这个人参与的行为和活动。这就是这个人哥伦比亚大学校园分发的东西。
The White House has talked about pro-Hamas flyers distributed at some Columbia protests. Did you know about flyers like that?
白宫谈到了在一些哥伦比亚抗议活动中分发的亲哈马斯传单。你知道这样的传单吗？
I did not. There's absolutely no truth to these allegations at all. Yeah, I would never. For so many reasons, I would never do that, for so, so many reasons. The protest is about ending the genocide and ending Colombia's complicity in war crimes. That was about it. Why would I bring such flyers? What would it do to the cause?
我不知道。这些指控绝对没有任何根据。是的，我绝对不会。出于这么多原因，我绝对不会那样做，出于这么多，这么多原因。抗议是关于结束种族灭绝，结束哥伦比亚大学在战争罪行中的共谋。仅此而已。我为什么要带那样的传单？这对事业有什么帮助？
The administration found a new line of attack on this subject this summer, when Mahmoud did not condemn Hamas in an interview on CNN and another interview on Ezra Klein's podcast, saying the question was a distraction and that he condemned the killing of all civilians. The Department of Homeland Security posted in response, quote, "Mahmoud Khalil refuses to condemn Hamas because he is a terrorist sympathizer, not because DHS painted him as one." As for the administration's bigger point, that the protests themselves were antisemitic, Mahmoud says exactly what so many people say, that it's possible to criticize Israel's actions in Gaza without being either antisemitic or aligned with Hamas.
今年夏天，当马哈茂德在CNN的采访和埃兹拉·克莱恩的播客采访中没有谴责哈马斯，说这个问题是一种干扰，并谴责杀害所有平民时，政府找到了攻击这个话题的新途径。国土安全部回应称，“马哈茂德·哈利勒拒绝谴责哈马斯是因为他是恐怖分子同情者，而不是因为国土安全部把他描绘成一个。”至于政府更大的观点，即抗议活动本身是反犹太主义的，马哈茂德说了很多人所说的话，即可以在不反犹太也不与哈马斯结盟的情况下批评以色列在加沙的行动。
One thing that's genuinely confusing about the administration's argument in all these student deportation cases is this idea that a student protester can somehow undermine US foreign policy. Like, what could that possibly mean? Sure, students were asking the government to change its foreign policy and not keep funding Israel. But urging some policy change is just normal politics in the United States. President Trump did it when he ran for office. That is not undermining any policy.
在所有这些学生驱逐案件中，关于政府论点有一个真正令人困惑的事情是，这种想法，即一个学生抗议者怎么可能破坏美国的外交政策。这可能意味着什么？当然，学生们是在要求政府改变其外交政策，不要继续资助以色列。但敦促政策改变只是美国的正常政治。特朗普总统在竞选公职时也这样做过。那根本不是破坏任何政策。
The only clue that the administration has given about what this might mean came in April, when the government submitted to the court a brief memo, from the secretary of state, saying that Mahmoud's presence in the United States, quote, "undermines US policy to combat antisemitism around the world and in the United States," but again, no explanation of how this one grad student, who is no longer a grad student, was achieving that lofty goal.
政府给出的关于这可能意味着什么的唯一线索是在四月，当时政府向法庭提交了一份来自国务卿的简短备忘录，称马哈茂德在美国的存在，“破坏了美国在全球和美国国内打击反犹太主义的政策”，但同样，没有解释这个现在已经不是研究生的一名研究生是如何实现那个崇高目标的。
In fact, in immigration court, the administration argued that it should not have to make any kind of argument or explanation or present any evidence at all for how Mahmoud is undermining US foreign policy. The government's lawyers argued that if the secretary of state says that that's true, then that's that, no discussion needed. That's all that's required to deport him. If the government wins this case, presumably the secretary of state would be able to declare, without any explanation or any proof, lots of other people are deportable.
事实上，在移民法庭上，政府辩称它根本不需要提出任何论点、解释或呈现任何证据，证明马哈茂德是如何破坏美国外交政策的。政府律师辩称，如果国务卿说是真的，那就是真的，不需要讨论。这足以将他驱逐出境。如果政府赢得了这场诉讼，国务卿大概将能够在没有任何解释或证据的情况下，宣布许多其他人是可驱逐的。
I did reach out to both the Department of Homeland Security and the State Department, asking how Mahmoud's actions undermine US foreign policy. The furthest I got was this not-very-illuminating answer to my question from a senior State Department official. Quote, "As you know, there's ongoing litigation with respect to this matter. However, our position is that the actions of the United States with respect to Mahmoud Khalil were correct and necessary and fully supported both by fact and by law."
我确实联系了国土安全部和国务院，询问马哈茂德的行为是如何破坏美国外交政策的。我得到的最大进展是国务院一名高级官员对我提出的这个问题给出的不太有启发性的回答。原文：“正如你所知，此事正在进行诉讼。然而，我们的立场是，美国对马哈茂德·哈利勒采取的行动是正确和必要的，且有事实和法律完全支持。”
In May, a federal judge ruled that the law that the government is using to go after Mahmoud is unconstitutionally vague. And then in June, the judge said that Mahmoud was likely being targeted for deportation by the administration for exercising his First Amendment right to free speech. And he set him free.
五月，一名联邦法官裁定政府用来对付马哈茂德的法律在宪法上模糊不清。然后在六月，法官表示马哈茂德很可能是因为行使宪法第一修正案的言论自由权而遭到政府的驱逐攻击。于是他下令将其释放。
Mahmoud flew home to New York June 21 after 104 days in detention. When Noor and Deen greeted him at the airport, it was only the second time Mahmoud had seen his son in person. The first was in a cold courtroom in Louisiana. And from the moment he returned to New York, there was something new derailing the life he had and Noor had planned-- his own fame.
马哈茂德在被拘留104天后，于6月21日飞回纽约。当努尔和迪恩在机场迎接他时，这是马哈茂德第二次亲自见到他的儿子。第一次是在路易斯安那州一个寒冷的法庭上。从他回到纽约的那一刻起，有一些新的东西让他和努尔计划的生活脱轨——他自己的名声。
Welcome home, Mahmoud Khalil.
欢迎回家，马哈茂德·哈利勒。
Welcome home, Mahmoud Khalil!
欢迎回家，马哈茂德·哈利勒！
Did you see Mahmoud Khalil?
你看到马哈茂德·哈利勒了吗？
Mahmoud Khalil.
马哈茂德·哈利勒。
Mahmoud Khalil back home in New York tonight.
马哈茂德·哈利勒今晚回到纽约家中。
His second day in New York, he was mobbed like the Beatles at a rally near Columbia. Security had to push people back. He gave a speech in front of a church, which his friend, Jasmine, decided to skip. She went inside the church and took care of Deen.
回到纽约的第二天，他在哥伦比亚大学附近的一场集会上被像披头士乐队那样围堵。保安不得不把人们往后推。他在教堂前发表了演讲，他的朋友茉莉决定不参加。她走进教堂，照顾迪恩。
But I wasn't going to watch him give a speech in front of people. I don't know. And he was like, why? And I was like, I don't want to see people looking at you that way. And Mahmoud-chella or Mahmoud Madness or whatever it was.
但我没打算看他在人们面前演讲。我不知道。他说，为什么？我说，我不想看人们那样看着你。还有什么“马哈茂德音乐节”或“马哈茂德疯狂”，不管那是什么。
Does he seem different?
他看起来有什么不同吗？
Yeah. He's not focused. There's a weird distraction. He's like a figurehead. People know who he is. There's a coffee shop near my house, and they have a big picture of Mahmoud on the door. So I go there every day. And I'm like, oh, there's Mahmoud on the door. Or I went to Times Square for some ungodly reason in the subway. And it's "Free Mahmoud" on one of the subway signs. I don't know if he really understood-- I couldn't grapple with that idea that everybody knows who he is.
是的。他不在状态。有一种奇怪的干扰。他就像一个象征人物。人们知道他是谁。我家附近有个咖啡馆，他们在门上贴了一张马哈茂德的大照片。所以我每天去那里。我就想，哦，门上有马哈茂德。或者我去时代广场，因为某种不可理喻的原因坐地铁。地铁标志牌上写着“释放马哈茂德”。我不知道他是否真正理解——我无法接受每个人都知道他是谁这个想法。
It's just a really strange thing for anybody to have to go through. Is it hard to get your mind around, though, just how well known you are?
这对任何人来说都是一件非常奇怪的事情。很难理解你有多出名，是吗？
I'm still comprehending that. So maybe I'm trying to push thinking about it. And yeah, to be honest, I haven't contemplated that as of yet.
我还在领悟中。所以也许我在努力不去想它。是的，说实话，我还没深入考虑过这个问题。
His fame-- it kind of annoys me, to be honest. [LAUGHS] Yeah.
他的名声——说实话，这让我有点恼火。[笑] 是的。
What do you mean, annoys?
你说的恼火是指什么？
It's just a reminder of how absurd the whole situation is. He shouldn't be famous. Nobody should know who he is. It doesn't make any sense. And that this reason why Mahmoud is famous is because something absurd happened that never should have happened. Yeah, it annoys me. It makes me angry. Because if he wanted this and voluntarily chose it, great. But to have it forced upon him like that, I don't like it.
这只是提醒人们整个局面有多荒谬。他不应该出名。没人应该知道他是谁。这毫无道理。马哈茂德出名的原因是因为发生了一些荒谬的事情，这些事本来就不应该发生。是的，这让我恼火。因为它让我愤怒。因为如果他想要这个并且自愿选择它，太好了。但被迫接受这种名声，我不喜欢。
Mahmoud's fame infected everything about their lives. A few weeks after he was released, they were still living in Columbia student housing, an apartment they'd have to move out of soon. Mahmoud was supposed to be finding an apartment for them. And he'd been putting it off.
马哈茂德的名声感染了他们生活的方方面面。他获释几周后，他们仍然住在哥伦比亚大学的学生公寓里，那是一个他们很快就得搬离的公寓。马哈茂德本该为他们找公寓。但他一直拖着。
Yeah, I procrastinate a lot. Noor hates that. We need to move in less than two weeks.
是的，我经常拖延。努尔讨厌那样。我们需要在不到两周内搬家。
And here we are. We don't have an apartment.
我们就是这样。我们没公寓。
Are you serious, less than two weeks?
你是认真的吗，不到两周？
Yeah, less than-- we need to move at the end of this month.
是的，不到——我们需要在这个月底前搬走。
Can you shop for apartments like normal people right now?
你现在能像正常人一样去买公寓吗？
I have my cap, so--
我有我的帽子，所以——
And he wears a cap all the time.
他一直戴着帽子。
Oh, you have a cap, like you're in disguise.
哦，你有帽子，就像你在伪装一样。
Yes, like in disguise.
是的，就像伪装一样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And it was funny. One of the agents was like, I've seen you somewhere. I was like, maybe. I'm not sure.
那很有趣。其中一个中介说，我在什么地方见过你。我说，也许吧。我不确定。
He played it off really well.
他表现得非常好。
Yeah. So--
是的。所以——
He needs the disguise because there have been so many threats against them. And he's recognized so often when he goes out without it. When Noor walks on the street with baby Deen, people come up to her. One time, a stranger asked, is that Mahmoud Khalil's son? She didn't know if it was going to be good or bad. It's scary. And mostly, they've avoided leaving the apartment. And when Mahmoud does decide to go outside, it's to go to Washington to spend the day talking to members of Congress or to stand on stage in front of 3,000 people with comedian Ramy Youssef and New York City mayoral candidate Zohran Mamdani.
他需要伪装，因为有太多针对他们的威胁了。而且他不戴帽子出去时经常被认出来。当努尔带着宝宝迪恩走在街上时，人们会走过来找她。有一次，一个陌生人问，那是马哈茂德·哈利勒的儿子吗？她不知道这会是好事还是坏事。很可怕。他们大多避免离开公寓。当马哈茂德决定出去时，是为了去华盛顿花一天时间与国会议员交谈，或者站在舞台上，面对3000名观众，和喜剧演员拉米·优素福以及纽约市长候选人佐兰·曼达尼在一起。
Mr. Mahmoud Khalil, everybody.
马哈茂德·哈利勒先生，女士们先生们。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
This positive side of his fame, the fact that people pay attention to him, seems, for now, to be deeply outweighed by the negative side. Mahmoud told us that, given the choice, he would no question prefer the life that he was lining up for this year-- the job at Oxfam, being there for Deen's birth, and not being famous-- over the life that he's ended up in. Case in point, it is really not clear what kind of job he's going to be able to get.
这种名声的积极一面，即人们关注他，目前似乎被消极一面深深掩盖了。马哈茂德告诉我们，如果有得选，他会毫无疑问地更愿意过他今年本打算过的那种生活——在乐施会的工作，在那儿见证迪恩的出生，不出名——而不是他最终陷入的这种生活。例如，他到底能找到什么样的工作真的很不清楚。
How do you picture what kind of work you're going to be able to get now?
你如何想象你现在能找到什么样的工作？
I'm trying to, as much as possible, to postpone having that conversation--
我正尽量，尽可能多地，推迟进行那样的对话——
You're saying--
你是说——
--with myself, just thinking, oh, now, I can't work for Oxfam or for an organization at the UN. And it's scary. And we did not have much money before my arrest. And until now, we don't have any money, to be honest.
——与我自己，只是想，哦，现在，我不能去乐施会或者联合国的一个组织工作了。这很可怕。我被捕前我们没什么钱。说实话，直到现在我们还没钱。
There are two different cases that are going to determine whether Mahmoud will be deported. One is in federal court and may be appealed all the way up to the Supreme Court. The other is in immigration court. That one could be decided in a few months and could result in his expulsion. If it does, the government says it'll either send him to Syria, where he was born but doesn't have citizenship, or to Algeria, where he's a citizen but has never lived.
有两个不同的案子将决定马哈茂德是否会被驱逐出境。一个在联邦法院，可能会一直上诉到最高法院。另一个在移民法庭。那个可能在几个月内做出决定，并可能导致他的驱逐。如果是这样，政府说它要么把他送到叙利亚，他在那里出生但没有公民身份，要么送到阿尔及利亚，他在那里是公民但从没住过。
I was at a hearing in immigration court where they talked about where to send him. Four expert witnesses said if he were sent to either place, Mahmoud would be at great risk to be harmed or killed. Probably the most heartwrenching moment of that hearing happened near the end of the day. Mahmoud said if he were deported, he wanted to go alone. He didn't want to expose Noor and Deen to any extra danger because of him.
我参加过一次移民法庭的听证会，他们谈论把他送到哪里。四名专家证人说，如果他被送到任何一个地方，马哈茂德将面临受到伤害或被杀害的极大风险。那场听证会最令人心碎的时刻可能发生在一天的快结束时。马哈茂德说，如果他被驱逐，他想一个人走。他不想因为他而让努尔和迪恩暴露在任何额外的危险中。
When he said this in his testimony, I looked over, and I could see Noor crying. Later, she told me this is how he always is, protective of her and his family, now Deen. It's sweet, she said, but sometimes she doesn't agree.
当他在证词中说出这一点时，我看了过去，我看到努尔在哭。后来她告诉我，他总是这样，保护她和他的家人，现在是迪恩。她说，这很贴心，但有时她不同意。
And that's where this interruption in their plans has left them. They don't know if they'll end up here or abroad, together or apart. They're waiting to see what the new plan for their life is going to be. Coming up, a 16-year-old plans a prank, and a complete stranger from Honduras ends up in a million-dollar deal. What could possibly go wrong with that? That's in a minute, Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
这就是他们的计划中断留给他们的结果。他们不知道他们最终会在这里还是国外，在一起还是分开。他们正在等待看看他们人生的新计划会是什么。接下来，一个16岁的孩子策划了一个恶作剧，而一个来自洪都拉斯的完全陌生人最终达成了一笔百万美元的交易。这可能会出什么问题？过一会儿再讲，芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Watch Out for That Tree-- stories of people who carefully, meticulously plan for one future, and then the plans are derailed by forces much bigger than they are. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Engineer.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《小心那棵树》——讲述人们仔细、严谨地计划未来，然后计划被比他们大得多的力量打乱的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，工程师。
The plan that goes a-kilter in this act is actually a prank, a prank done years ago by a child who has now grown up into an adult. His name's Kieran. As a kid growing up in England, he was obsessed with soccer. And his first baby pranks happened on the day that soccer teams in England finished adding new players to their rosters. This always got live TV coverage. Kieran and his friend would head down to where the cameras were set up, doing live news spots.
在这一幕中出岔子的计划其实是一个恶作剧，一个多年前由现在已经成年的孩子所做的恶作剧。他的名字叫基兰。作为在英国长大的孩子，他痴迷于足球。他的第一次婴儿级恶作剧发生在英国足球队完成新球员招募的那一天。这总是能得到现场直播的报道。基兰和他的朋友会前往设置摄像机的地方，进行现场新闻直播。
And we'd walk over, and we'd just stare really blankly into the camera, like yokels that hadn't seen technology before. And then we'd rush back, and we'd see if anyone had seen it on TV and be like, oh, my god. Who are those freaks in the back? And that was us.
我们会走过去，然后茫然地直视镜头，就像没见过科技的乡巴佬一样。然后我们会冲回去，看看电视上有没有人看到，心想，天哪。后面那两个怪人是谁？那就是我们。
But then when they got to middle-school age, they got more ambitious with their pranking. They wanted to start a rumor and get it onto their favorite TV channel, Sky Sports News. Kieran says they designed the rumor to be kind of amusing but also plausible. The rumor they made up was that the soccer player, William Gallas, was going to sign with a not very good team, Birmingham.
但当他们到了中学年龄时，他们的恶作剧变得更有野心了。他们想散布一个谣言，并把它弄到他们最喜欢的电视频道天空体育新闻（Sky Sports News）上。基兰说，他们设计的谣言既有趣又可信。他们编造的谣言是，足球运动员威廉·加拉（William Gallas）要签约一支不太好的球队，伯明翰。
Like, lower mid-table, dowdy old Birmingham. He's on the out. He's old. It could happen. Let's try and just put some calls in.
就像，中下游球队，沉闷的老伯明翰。他要过气了。他老了。这可能会发生。让我们试着打几个电话。
So these kids, they called up a hotel in Birmingham and booked a room in the player's name. This player, William Gallas, is French. So Kieran pretended to be a French sports agent with a kind of terrible French accent.
所以这些孩子给伯明翰的一家酒店打电话，用这名球员的名字订了一个房间。这名球员威廉·加拉是法国人。所以基兰假装成一名带有糟糕法国口音的法国体育经纪人。
(IN FRENCH ACCENT) I was talking like this. So can I have-- I have roomate who's coming in. My client, William-- oh, you cannot tell what it is for. It is for Birmingham.
（用法国口音）我说话就是这样。所以给我——我有室友要来。我的客户，威廉——哦，你不能说它是为了什么。它是为了伯明翰。
That task finished. Room is reserved. He called up the press.
那个任务完成了。房间预订好了。他给新闻界打了电话。
It was as easy as saying to a few papers, I've just heard from my friend who works at the Malmaison, the hotel-- don't take it from me. But apparently, William Gallas has booked a room. He's coming in tonight. And then telling Sky Sports all of this, oh, my god, my phone's been blowing up. Apparently, William Gallas is going to Birmingham. I've heard it from this guy at this paper. I've heard it from the guy at the hotel.
这就跟告诉几家报纸一样简单，我刚从我在马尔梅森（Malmaison）酒店工作的朋友那里听说——别只听我一个人说。但显然，威廉·加拉订了一个房间。他今晚要来。然后把所有这些都告诉天空体育，哦，天哪，我的电话一直被打爆。显然，威廉·加拉要去伯明翰。我是从这个报社的家伙那里听到的。我是从酒店的家伙那里听到的。
And then the next morning, we're watching Sky Sports News again. There's a flash interview with Alex McLeish, who was the manager at the time. And it's just 10 seconds of, oh, you've been linked with William Gallas. Do you have anything to say about that?
然后第二天早上，我们又在看天空体育新闻。有一个关于亚历克斯·麦克利什（Alex McLeish）的即兴采访，他当时是主教练。只有10秒钟的片段，哦，你和威廉·加拉联系在一起了。你有什么要说的吗？
No. No, nothing. And I've got two young center-halves, and it's not the right move for me. I need to spend my money on other positions that-- or spend the club's money on other positions that we really need to improve things.
不。不，没什么。我有两个年轻的中后卫，这对我来说不是正确的举动。我需要把我的钱花在其他位置上——或者把俱乐部的钱花在我们确实需要改进的其他位置上。
That was one of the funniest moments of our entire lives. It's just like being just hit by a tsunami. It was just, oh, my god. It was here, sat on this floor by this TV yesterday. Today, it is coming out of the TV. This is ridiculously powerful. It's like, if we can do that, what else can we do?
那是我们一生中最有趣的时刻之一。感觉就像被海啸击中一样。就是，天哪。昨天我还坐在电视旁边的地板上。今天，它就从电视里出来了。这威力太大了。心想，如果我们能做到这一点，我们还能做什么？
That "what else can we do?" is the plan that they launched into next, a plan that succeeded at a level that stunned these two kids. OK. So I first heard this story on a podcast I've been listening to Pablo Torre Finds Out, which-- I don't know exactly how to describe this. It's sort of an investigative reporting sports show that's also pretty funny. Anyway, Kieran told the story to Pablo, and then Pablo agreed to adapt it for our show. And so here now to tell you this story is Pablo Torre.
那个“我们还能做什么？”是他们接下来启动的计划，一个让这两个孩子震惊的成功的计划。好的。所以我第一次听到这个故事是在我一直在听的播客《巴勃罗·托雷找出真相》（Pablo Torre Finds Out）中，这——我不知道该怎么确切描述这个。这是一种调查报道体育节目，但也相当有趣。无论如何，基兰把这个故事告诉了巴勃罗，巴勃罗同意为我们的节目改编它。现在来讲这个故事的人是巴勃罗·托雷。
At age 16, Kieran Morris was experiencing what can only be described as a puberty of the ego. He was still light headed, a little high off the intoxicating success of his French accent, and now he wanted more. He wanted to go big-game hunting, find another soccer player and engineer an even bigger prank on the global soccer media. The only question was which player they should use. And then one day, in the summer of 2012, the London Olympics happened to be on TV, Honduras versus Morocco.
16岁时，基兰·莫里斯正在经历只能被描述为自我青春期的事情。他仍然飘飘然，有点沉醉于他法国口音的成功，现在他想要更多。他想去狩猎更大的猎物，寻找另一名足球运动员，并对全球足球媒体策划一个更大的恶作剧。唯一的问题是他们应该使用哪名球员。然后有一天，在2012年夏天，伦敦奥运会碰巧在电视上播出，洪都拉斯对摩洛哥。
It's-- ooh, is there anyone here? Let's look through the squad list. And we looked at a few. A few of them had already gone to Europe. A few of them already had a bit of hype around them. But there was a 19-year-old, number 10, making his first waves into the national team. He was fairly dynamic on the day. His name was Alexander Lopez. He hadn't left Honduras. He had a pretty modest but good goal record, a little bit of detail on him.
在那儿，哦，有人吗？让我们看看阵容名单。我们看了几个。其中几个已经去了欧洲。其中几个已经有点被炒作了。但有一个19岁的，10号，第一次在国家队崭露头角。他那天相当有活力。他的名字叫亚历山大·洛佩兹（Alexander Lopez）。他还没有离开洪都拉斯。他有一个相当不错但有记录的进球，关于他的一些细节。
And I don't know what it was, but we just fixed our eyes on him. And before we know it, we're at the big, boxy computer in the study, going through Wikipedia, juicing it up a little bit with a bit more bio here.
我不知道是什么原因，但我们的目光固定在了他身上。在我们意识到之前，我们就在书房里那个大盒状电脑前，翻看着维基百科，用更多的传记润色一下。
What are you editing on Wikipedia?
你在维基百科上编辑什么？
Oh, basically, at this point, it's a blank page. So a season had just gone by, the '11-'12 season. It had no detail on it. Let's give him some references for a great series of goals in the Honduran league.
哦，基本上，此时这是一个空白页。一个赛季刚刚过去，11-12赛季。它没有细节。让我们给他增加一些洪都拉斯联赛伟大进球系列的参考资料。
So they went in a few times over months and kept juicing the numbers.
所以他们几个月里去了几次，不断地增加数字。
Statistically, what are you giving him? What kind of an upgrade are you giving him?
从统计学上讲，你给他什么？你给了他什么样的升级？
18 goals, 34 assists, crazy, crazy, crazy figures. If you watch a player do that to your league, they're an object of fascination. Other people are rising with his tide. He's that talented. The assists, I always thought, were the flourish.
18个进球，34次助攻，疯狂，疯狂，疯狂的数字。如果你看一个球员在你的联赛中这样做，他们就是一个迷人的对象。其他人随着他的浪潮而上升。他就是那么有才华。助攻，我一直认为，是点缀。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But from the beginning, the boldest thing they did is something you can still see right now, forever etched into the Wikipedia history of the page for Olympia midfielder Alexander Lopez. Because Kieran Morris went back to add one more line, a nickname, which be placed at the very top.
但从一开始，他们做的最大胆的事情是你可以现在仍然看到的东西，永远蚀刻在奥林匹亚中场球员亚历山大·洛佩兹页面的维基百科历史中。因为基兰·莫里斯回去增加了一行，一个昵称，他放在了最顶端。
He is known to Olympia fans as the Honduran Maradona.
他被奥林匹亚球迷称为“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Diego Maradona is one of the two or three greatest players in the history of soccer. That sound was him achieving immortality in the 1986 World Cup for Argentina against England. He is also one of its most colorfully reckless characters, to say the least. And all of this is to say that Kieran comparing an effectively anonymous soccer player named Alexander Lopez to Diego Maradona was absurd, a real heat check.
迭戈·马拉多纳是足球史上最伟大的两三名球员之一。那个声音是他1986年世界杯为阿根廷对阵英格兰实现不朽时刻。他也是足球界最色彩斑斓、鲁莽的角色之一，至少可以这样说。这一切都是说，基兰把一个实际上默默无闻的叫亚历山大·洛佩兹的足球运动员比作迭戈·马拉多纳是荒谬的，是一个真正的疯狂测试。
But for the people who'd never paid attention to soccer in Honduras, meaning pretty much everyone, this nickname was also plausible. And so the next step of Kieran's plan was to call up a newspaper, Rupert Murdoch's London Times. And the persona Kieran invented this time was an eager freelance journalist named Neil Barker. And as soon as Neil Barker heard a human voice on the other line, he pitched that human an item he had just heard about an Olympic-level prospect named Alexander Lopez.
但对于那些从未关注洪都拉斯足球的人来说，这意味着几乎每个人，这个昵称也是可信的。所以基兰计划的下一步是打电话给一家报纸，鲁珀特·默多克的伦敦《泰晤士报》。基兰这次发明的人物是一个叫尼尔·巴克（Neil Barker）的热情自由撰稿记者。尼尔·巴克一听到线路另一头的人声，就向那个人推销了他刚听到的关于一个奥运级别希望之星亚历山大·洛佩兹的消息。
Because the Honduran Maradona, Neil Barker said, was signing with Wigan, a team in the English Premier League based in Greater Manchester. And Neil Barker sounded legit.
因为“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”，尼尔·巴克说，要签约威根（Wigan），一支位于大曼彻斯特的英超球队。尼尔·巴克听起来很合法。
Oh, I think he talked a bit like this. So it was a bit more a bit more Mancunian and a bit more-- yeah, so I've heard a little bit about Wigan signing another Honduran lad. He's playing at the Olympics now. He's called Alexander Lopez. Apparently, he's really, really good. $2 and 1/2 million is what I've heard from the physio.
哦，我想他说话有点像这样。所以它更像曼彻斯特口音，更像——是的，我听说了一点关于威根签约另一个洪都拉斯小伙的事。他正在奥运会上踢球。他叫亚历山大·洛佩兹。显然，他真的，真的很好。250万美元是我从理疗师那里听到的。
Oh, you're the physio's friend.
哦，你是理疗师的朋友。
I was the physio's friend. You just piece it together like that, where it's, ooh, a physio's friend could have let that slip. A medical could be happening. And then The Times-- I remember I was on the phone with a guy for 20 minutes, and he was taking down every detail. I think, for the very least, The Times, when they put it in the paper, they believed it.
我是理疗师的朋友。你就像那样把它拼凑起来，哦，理疗师的朋友可能漏了口风。体检可能正在发生。然后《泰晤士报》——我记得我和那个人通了20分钟电话，他在记下每一个细节。我想，至少，《泰晤士报》在报纸上刊登时，他们是相信它的。
And then the year afterwards, we saw the news that the Houston Dynamo had paid $1 million for Alexander Lopez. We just thought, oh, my god. There were the stats on the press release-- 18 goals, 34 assists. They had a YouTube clip of him up.
然后第二年，我们看到了休斯顿迪纳摩队（Houston Dynamo）支付100万美元签下亚历山大·洛佩兹的消息。我们只是想，哦，天哪。新闻稿上有统计数据——18个进球，34次助攻。他们上传了他的YouTube剪辑。
The comments of that had welcome, the Honduran Maradona. We looked at the SB Nation posts, and we looked at the Reddit boards. And there it was. We'd looked away for, like, a second. And this wildfire seemingly had spread through Major League Soccer.
那下面的评论有欢迎“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”。我们看了SB Nation的帖子，我们看了Reddit板块。它就在那儿。我们才移开眼睛，像一秒钟一样。这场野火似乎已经蔓延到美国职业足球大联盟（MLS）。
I'm now looking at the press release off of houstondynamofc.com. And it says, quote, "His record of 18 goals and 34 assists in 51 league games for Olympia testifies"-- testifies-- "to his creative and goal-scoring potential," which feels like you wrote that. But no, this just got aggregated everywhere. You look it up now, and it's like foxnews.com has a story about this, quoting those numbers. And there's this one fan site. They're not just quoting the statistics, Kieran. They're quoting the legend, the nickname that you invented out of nothing.
我现在正在看houstondynamofc.com上的新闻稿。它写道，原文，“他在奥林匹亚51场联赛中18个进球和34次助攻的记录见证”——见证——“了他的创造力和进球潜力，”这感觉像是你写的。但没有，这只是到处聚合在一起。你现在查一下，就像foxnews.com有一个关于这个的故事，引用了这些数字。还有一个粉丝网站。他们不只是在引用统计数据，基兰。他们还在引用这个传说，这个你凭空发明的昵称。
Yeah. As soon as I saw that press release-- I was sat down in my study on the other side of the city, where I lived. And it's the one where he's holding the shirt. And it says Alex 10, got the number 10, Maradona's number, holding it proudly in orange in the sun in Houston. And the first thing I did was, I made it my laptop background. I put it on the wall like a hunting trophy. I was just like, there we go. There we have it.
是的。我一看到那篇新闻稿——我坐在城市另一边的书房里，我住在那儿。就是他拿着球衣的那张。上面写着Alex 10，得到了10号，马拉多纳的号码，在休斯顿的阳光下骄傲地拿着橙色的球衣。我做的第一件事是，我把它设成了我的电脑背景。我把它像狩猎战利品一样挂在墙上。我当时想，就是这样。我们做到了。
You're a terror.
你是个恐怖分子。
I know.
我知道。
What a terror you were-- are.
你真是个恐怖分子——或者过去是。
Were, I hope. I think I'm reformed.
过去是，我希望。我想我已经改过自新了。
The Houston Dynamo signing the Honduran Maradona immediately became Kieran's defining story, because of course it did. Kieran Morris told the story of how he pranked this dumb soccer team-- these credulous Americans in Texas who were so unfamiliar with his favorite sport that he conned him into dropping a million dollars on an edited Wikipedia page-- and he told this yarn, in those terms, to anyone and everyone who would listen.
休斯顿迪纳摩签下“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”立即成为了基兰的定义故事，因为它当然会是这样。基兰·莫里斯讲述了他是如何恶作剧这支愚蠢的足球队——这些在德克萨斯州轻信的美国人，他们对他最喜欢的运动如此不熟悉，以至于他骗他们在一个编辑过的维基百科页面上扔了100万美元——他讲述了这个故事，用这些词，给任何愿意听的人。
Oh, yeah, directly, directly led me to jobs, directly led me into what I do today. The magazine job that I have today, I pitched doing the Honduran Maradona, the whole run through, in my job interview. It's, hire me. I'm precocious. I can take a kid from Central America and make him into a millionaire. What could I do for you? And--
哦，是的，直接，直接带给了我工作，直接带给了我现在所做的事情。我今天拥有的杂志工作，我在工作面试中推销了“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”的故事，全程。那是，雇用我吧。我早熟。我可以把一个来自中美洲的孩子变成百万富翁。我能为你做什么？而且——
I like the idea of you bragging about this, like on dates.
我喜欢你在约会时吹嘘这件事的想法。
Well, my now fiance-- I started going out with Sarah, who will be listening-- hello-- at the end of 2014. So it's nine years. So it's just after school. And so it worked on her years and years ago, nine years ago. She hates every beat, every turn, every single mention of Alexander Lopez, because she has heard me pull that routine hundreds of times with hundreds of different people.
嗯，我现在未婚妻——我开始和莎拉约会，她会听到的——你好——是在2014年底。所以是九年了。就在学校之后。所以它在多年前，九年前对她有效。她讨厌每一个节奏，每一个转折，每一个对亚历山大·洛佩兹的提及，因为她听过我用数百种方式对数百个不同的人讲过那个惯例。
She rolls her eyes, like, default. All of this hype around this story that was all tied into this hype I did around myself, never once did I think, what has happened to him? What really has happened to him, to his family? And that, bit by bit, as I got older, that became a bigger thing in my mind.
她翻白眼，就像，默认一样。所有围绕这个故事的炒作都和我围绕自己的炒作联系在一起，我从来没想过，他怎么了？他的家庭到底发生了什么？而随着我年龄增长，那在我的脑海中变成了一件更大的事情。
Lopez only lasted a few seasons in Houston-- didn't play a lot. And Kieran began to wonder if his prank had been part of the reason things worked out so badly for Alexander Lopez, if he had callously tampered with the life of a promising young soccer player, setting him up for a fall in Houston, giving fans unrealistic expectations, disappointing coaches and teammates. Kieran felt guilty. And so, about a decade later, Kieran pitched yet another British newspaper, the Guardian this time, on the untold backstory of the Honduran Maradona, the true story of what he'd done.
洛佩兹在休斯顿只坚持了几个赛季——没怎么踢。基兰开始怀疑他的恶作剧是否是导致亚历山大·洛佩兹最终结局如此糟糕的原因之一，他是否冷酷地篡改了一个有前途的年轻足球运动员的生活，为他在休斯顿的失败做好了铺垫，给球迷们不切实际的期望，让教练和队友失望。基兰感到内疚。所以，大约十年后，基兰推销了另一家英国报纸，这次是《卫报》，讲述“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”的未被披露的背景故事，他所做之事的真实故事。
This reporting trip-- this guilt trip-- is what brought Kieran Morris at long last to Houston, home of the hapless Dynamo, where he could finally discover what really happened once his million-dollar invention showed up for work. Dynamo management remembered Lopez clearly.
这次报道之旅——这次内疚之旅——是基兰·莫里斯最终来到休斯顿的原因，不幸的迪纳摩队的主场，在那里他终于可以发现他的百万美元发明在上班后真正发生了什么。迪纳摩管理层清楚地记得洛佩兹。
He was like, he was a really nice kid when he arrived. And he was fresh faced and eager. There was a big-Spanish speaking contingent in the club, as there is in the city. And they just helped him settle in and get his fitness up. But what I've heard from speaking with Dom Kinnear, who was the manager at the time, was that fitness was, I think, the big obstacle for adapting to the MLS.
他就像是，他刚到时是个非常可爱的孩子。他面孔清爽，急切。俱乐部里有一个很大的讲西班牙语的群体，正如城市里那样。他们只是帮他安顿下来，恢复体能。但我从与当时的主教练多姆·金尼尔（Dom Kinnear）交谈中听到的，体能，我认为是适应美国职业足球大联盟（MLS）的最大障碍。
I think at first, I think the speed of play and the physicalness of the players nonetheless were a little bit different than what he was used to in Honduras. It's just that we were expecting a bit more of an attacking presence from him. And I think it took him a little while to get adjusted.
我认为起初，我想比赛的速度和球员的身体素质毕竟与他在洪都拉斯习惯的有一点不同。只是我们期望他能有更多的进攻表现。我想他花了一些时间才适应。
What did they scout, actually? What did they tell you about what they saw themselves, in terms of them evaluating him? What did they do?
他们到底侦察了什么？他们在评估他时，告诉过你他们自己看到了什么？他们做了什么？
Oh, they flew out and watched games in Honduras. They put their due diligence in to monitor him and watch videos and all of these things to make sure that this guy was something good.
哦，他们飞过去看洪都拉斯的比赛。他们尽职调查去监控他并观看视频以及所有这些事情，以确保这个家伙是好东西。
We did take a trip down to Honduras to watch him play for his club. And he passed all the tests for us. And it was after that that we set up a meeting with our owners to let them know there's interest in a Honduran player south of the border who has a bright future.
我们确实去了一趟洪都拉斯看他为他的俱乐部踢球。他通过了我们所有的测试。在那之后，我们安排了与我们所有者的一次会议，让他们知道边境以南有一名洪都拉斯球员，他有一个光明的未来。
But as the MLS was professionalizing and intensifying, you need to run a lot more. You need to run a lot, lot more. You need to contribute to all sides of the game. You need to be that modern, total footballer, to an extent.
但随着MLS在专业化和加剧，你需要跑得更多。你需要跑很多，很多。你需要为比赛的各个方面做出贡献。在某种程度上，你需要成为那个现代的、全面的足球运动员。
You kind of need to be a bit more like the Honduran Maradona that was promised, who was, again, like Maradona, one of the fastest and most physical athletes, as well as one of the most infamous, right? But he's known for his athleticism, his physicality, his speed-- also, obviously, rampant cocaine use, as a side note. But the point is that the guy who arrived, he was less than, unsurprisingly, what that fake nickname you made up had suggested.
你有点需要更像承诺的那个“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”，他，再次，像马拉多纳，是最快和最具身体素质的运动员之一，也是最臭名昭著的角色之一，对吧？但他以运动能力、身体素质、速度闻名——也显然，可卡因的猖獗使用，作为旁注。但重点是，到达那里的家伙，与其说是那个你编造的假昵称所暗示的，不如说是不出所料。
Exactly. And early doors, I watched-- I think it was first game against New York Red Bulls. And there's a moment he pulls out this amazing pass to, I think, Jason Johnson. And he scores to make it, I think, 1-1 with the Dynamo.
正是如此。起初，我看了——我想那是对阵纽约红牛队的第一场比赛。有一刻他发出了一个惊人的传球，我想，传给杰森·约翰逊（Jason Johnson）。他进球使比分，我想，1-1平迪纳摩。
And there's Lopez. That's what he can do. Lopez, Johnson, has tied it up. Spectacular goal!
就是洛佩兹。那就是他能做的。洛佩兹，约翰逊，扳平比分。壮观的进球！
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Alexander Lopez with a passing gem and a first-ever goal for Jason Johnson.
亚历山大·洛佩兹的一个传球珍宝和杰森·约翰逊的第一个进球。
And then the Dynamo get turned over. They lose 4-1. The season generally falls off the rails fairly quickly.
然后迪纳摩被翻盘了。他们输了4-1。赛季总体上很快就脱轨了。
And as Kieran was canvassing the training ground, talking to all these people who work for the Dynamo, he started realizing something important. He discovered that the people he thought were these credulous Americans had actually done the research. They'd taken some international trips to Honduras themselves. It was one thing to write that press release and copy those fake statistics off Wikipedia, which the Dynamo clearly did, but they hadn't outsourced their entire scouting department to some British teenager.
当基兰在训练场上拉票，与为迪纳摩工作的所有这些人交谈时，他开始意识到一些重要的事情。他发现他认为那些轻信的美国人实际上做过调查。他们自己也进行过几次去洪都拉斯的国际旅行。写那份新闻稿并从维基百科上复制那些假统计数据是一回事，迪纳摩显然做了，但他们没有把整个侦察部门外包给一个英国青少年。
Well, I remember the one that really set me back was speaking to Dom Kinnear. And I asked him, have you ever heard the nickname, the Honduran Maradona? And he sort of rocks back in his chair. And he smiles, and he laughs, and he goes--
嗯，我记得让我退缩的那一次是和多姆·金尼尔交谈。我问他，你听说过“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”这个昵称吗？他坐在椅子上摇了摇。他微笑着，大笑着，他说——
I've heard some nicknames in my day, but the first I heard that was from you today.
我这辈子听过不少昵称，但这是我今天从你这儿听到的第一次。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--Kieran, I haven't heard that until you said it just now, like, literally never. Like, OK, check one on that. Chris Canetti, who was the president at the time of Houston Dynamo, he very breezily, almost offhandedly, said, yeah, yeah, we heard of that.
——基兰，直到你刚才说之前我都没听过，就像，字面上从未听过。好的，那项检查第一。克里斯·卡内蒂（Chris Canetti），当时休斯顿迪纳摩的主席，他非常漫不经心，几乎漫不经心地说，是的，是的，我们听说过。
Yeah, we knew about that at the time of the signing, but didn't make too much of that. [LAUGHS]
是的，我们签约时知道那个，但没怎么在意。[笑]
I don't think he-- not meant it, but I think what he meant by that was, we knew there was some hype around him. Because it was so breezily tossed off. It didn't give me anything like, oh, yeah, he's heard it. And then Nick Kalba, the assistant GM, was just clear as anything. Nope.
我想他并没有——不是那个意思，但我认为他那话的意思是，我们知道围绕他有一些炒作。因为它是如此漫不经心地被抛出。它没给我任何像，哦，是的，他听说过。然后尼克·卡尔巴（Nick Kalba），助理总经理，简直再清楚不过了。没听过。
Yeah. You get the Honduran Messi. You'll get the whatever. So I don't really take stock in somebody's nickname, to be honest.
是的。你会得到“洪都拉斯梅西”。你会得到什么什么。所以我对某人的昵称并不太在意，说实话。
Even if we did hear it, we wouldn't care, because those nicknames don't matter to us in the professional soccer industry.
即使我们听到了，我们也不会在乎，因为那些昵称对职业足球行业来说对我们无关紧要。
What you're thinking as your life, the story you tell yourself about yourself, is just being dismissed as just obviously unserious, like of course we don't give a [BLEEP] about that. That's just a thing someone says. When they tell you that the legend doesn't even matter to them, who made the decision, what's going through your head?
你认为的作为你的人生，你告诉自己的关于你自己的故事，只是被当作显然不严肃的东西被驳回了，就像当然我们不在乎那些（脏话）。那只是别人说的一件事。当他们告诉你那个传说对他们来说根本无关紧要时，谁做出了决定，你的脑子里在想什么？
I think the first thought was that I'm a long way from home, that I have got this far-- what-- 12-hours flight over, FaceTime with sports executives who've taken time out of their day to speak to me and just thinking, oh, god, why did I even lift under the rock with this one? I could have just kept on not bothering the story, leaving the ghosts to rest and all of that.
我想第一个念头是我离家很远，我已经到了这儿——什么——12小时飞行，与抽出时间与我交谈的体育主管视频通话，只是心想，哦，上帝，我为什么要挖这个坑？我可以一直不麻烦这个故事，让鬼魂安息等等。
And I didn't. And I picked at the scab too much. And now it's all coming out. Now I'm seeing it. Now I'm in the room with the adults, the adults who made the decisions, the proper people, who weren't just spinning yarns and telling stories in smoking areas and all of that, with the actual people doing their job. To think that I've been entertaining the idea that one day, they opened up their laptops while they were watching the Olympics, just as I was, and thought, ooh, look at all these goals and assists-- Chris, go get your checkbook-- when you see it all now.
但我没有。我把伤疤抠得太厉害了。现在一切都出来了。现在我看到了。现在我和成年人们在一个房间里，那些做出决定的成年人，那些正经人，他们不只是在吸烟区旋转纱线和讲故事，而是真正的人在做他们的工作。一想到我一直在娱乐那种想法，某天，他们打开笔记本电脑看奥运会时，就像我一样，想，哦，看看所有的进球和助攻——克里斯，去拿你的支票簿——当你现在看到这一切。
Just-- Kieran, what a literal child's version of how sports works.
简直——基兰，体育是如何运作的真是太孩子气的版本了。
But there was one more thing that Kieran had to do now that he was telling the true story of the Honduran Maradona. And it was simple. Kieran Morris needed to come clean to Alexander Lopez himself. No, Kieran hadn't ruined Lopez's life, it turned out. But he tried to mess with it, did his best, gave him that absurd nickname without ever really thinking through the consequences. So this was a kind of weird confession.
但既然基兰在讲“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”的真实故事，他还有一件事必须要做。这很简单。基兰·莫里斯需要向亚历山大·洛佩兹本人坦白。不，事实证明，基兰并没有毁了洛佩兹的人生。但他试图干扰它，尽了最大努力，给了他那个荒谬的昵称，却从未真正考虑过后果。所以这是一种奇怪的忏悔。
Lopez was now playing for a team in Costa Rica. Kieran found his agent, calmed his own nerves, and, without explaining to the agent why he kept on insisting on interviewing Alexander Lopez in person, Kieran got on a plane. And one day, at a Costa Rican Hilton, the Honduran Maradona walked in.
洛佩兹现在在哥斯达黎加的一支球队踢球。基兰找到了他的经纪人，平复了自己的情绪，而且，没向经纪人解释为什么他一直坚持要亲自采访亚历山大·洛佩兹，基兰上了飞机。有一天，在哥斯达黎加的一家希尔顿酒店，“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”走了进来。
We shook hands. It was journalist and subject, sit down, interpreter in the middle.
我们握了手。那是记者和对象，坐下，中间有口译员。
Kieran Mara speaking.
基兰·马拉（基兰莫里斯的别名）说话。
Eliana Castillo, the translator.
口译员埃利亚纳·卡斯蒂略。
And Alex Lopez, Alex Lopez.
还有亚历克斯·洛佩兹。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Si.
是的。
They talked through his career. Lopez had no bad memories of Houston. He had a rough time on a Saudi Arabian team for a while but quit that contract, went to Honduras.
他们谈论了他的职业生涯。洛佩兹对休斯顿没有不好的回忆。他有一段时间在沙特阿拉伯的一支球队过得很难，但解除了那份合同，去了洪都拉斯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And that run back in Honduras, he was banging in the goals. He was winning trophies. He was an all free-flowing, goal-scoring number 10 in Honduras. He finally had the record that we had made up for him when he was 19. At 24 or whatever he was then, he was ripping up the Honduran league.
在那场洪都拉斯的跑步比赛中，他砰砰地进球。他赢得了奖杯。他是洪都拉斯一名全面、进球如麻的10号球员。他终于有了我们19岁时为他编造的记录。在24岁或随便什么年龄时，他正在撕裂洪都拉斯联赛。
And after stalling for as long as he could with details about Lopez's career, Kieran started edging up to the reason he was even there. Had Lopez ever heard of this nickname, the Honduran Maradona?
在尽可能多地用关于洛佩兹职业生涯的细节拖延时间后，基兰开始边缘化他甚至在那里的原因。洛佩兹听说过“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”这个昵称吗？
He had. He absolutely had. He had heard it. But he thought it was just a fun, silly nickname made up by the fans.
他听过。他绝对听过。他听说过。但他以为这只是球迷编造的一个有趣、愚蠢的昵称。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The surname came along simply because a lot of newspapers and journalists were talking about it, and they would say that I was like a young Maradona. I had the same skills that Maradona had when he was that age too. I know that. But, of course, we all know that Maradona-- you know, what he was, really. So it's just that.
姓氏是随着报纸和记者谈论它而来的，他们会说我像年轻的马拉多纳。我也拥有马拉多纳那个年龄时拥有的相同技能。我知道这一点。但，当然，我们都知道马拉多纳——你知道，他到底是什么。所以就是这样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And that was about as far as it went. And there was a split second where I thought, shake hands and let him go-- tiniest split second. But I don't know what dragged me out of that. And I can hear it on the interview tape, those first stutters, like, excuse me, um, before you go, um--
事情大概就是这样。有一瞬间我觉得，握手然后让他走——极小的一瞬间。但我不知道是什么把我从那里拖了出来。我能在采访带上听到它，那些最初的口吃，比如，打扰一下，嗯，在你走之前，嗯——
One thing, one more thing while I'm here and while I have you.
一件事，在我在着的时候还有一件事。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then I've already rehearsed the spiel with the interpreter so she's not--
我已经和口译员排练过那套说辞了，所以她不会——
Oh, I feel so awkward--
哦，我觉得好尴尬——
--caught off guard.
——被措手不及。
--imagining this.
——想象这个。
So beat for beat, I'll do, like, 1/10 of the story. And then I'll pause. And then she'll do it in Spanish.
所以节奏上，我会做故事的十分之一。然后我会停顿。然后她会用西班牙语做出来。
When you were linked with Wigan, I had changed Wikipedia around. I had called the papers.
当你和威根联系在一起时，我改变了维基百科。我给报纸打了电话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then I will do the next bit and the next bit. And then it's all of those moments where-- I'm talking, and he's not reacting. But then I just sit back and watch his reaction. I'm studying him while I'm waiting to say something again. And I just keep talking and talking and talking.
然后我会做下一部分，再下一部分。所有的那些瞬间——我在说话，他没有反应。但我只是坐下来观察他的反应。我在研究他，同时等待再次说些什么。我一直说，说，说。
10 years ago, I invented the name the Honduran Maradona.
10年前，我发明了“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”这个名字。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's me.
是我。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he starts laughing. And then I'm like, that could mean a multitude of things. But he thought it was funny and benign and inconsequential and saw it for what it was, which was nothing.
他开始笑。然后我想，那可能意味着很多事情。但他觉得这很有趣，温和，无关紧要，并看到了它是什么，那就是什么都没有。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
When my agent told me a journalist wanted to do an interview, I was sort of like, huh? Why? But now I get it.
当我的经纪人告诉我一名记者想做采访时，我有点，嗯？为什么？但现在我明白了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
How does he feel about using that nickname, the Honduran Maradona? Does he embrace it? What's his feeling on that?
他怎么看使用“洪都拉斯马拉多纳”那个昵称？他拥抱它吗？他对那个有什么感觉？
Oh, no, he was very old school about it. He was like, oh, no, no, no. There's only one Maradona. But he's got a better nickname now. He's The Engineer, el ingeniero, as they call him. And his mom loves it. I think his brother actually is an engineer, so it's cool for them. The fans gave it to him, which is how nicknames should work. And it sums him up. He dictates play from the middle of the field. He's crafty. He's intelligent. It's who he is. And it wasn't randomly made up by a child.
哦，不，他在这方面非常老派。他说，哦，不，不，不。只有一个马拉多纳。但他现在有个更好的昵称。他是“工程师”（el ingeniero），正如他们叫他的那样。他妈妈很喜欢。我想他兄弟实际上是个工程师，所以这对他们来说很酷。球迷给了他那个昵称，这就是昵称应该工作的方式。它概括了他。他指挥比赛从中场。他狡猾。他聪明。这就是他。而且它不是一个孩子随意编造出来的。
That nickname, The Engineer, is so perfect. It's so perfect because Kieran thought he was the engineer rerouting Alexander Lopez's life. But he wasn't. This entire time, Alexander Lopez had been engineering Alexander Lopez's trajectory, because of course he was, through all the ups and downs which meant that the legend that Kieran had most invented was his own.
那个昵称，“工程师”，太完美了。太完美了，因为基兰以为他是指挥亚历山大·洛佩兹人生的工程师。但他不是。整个这段时间，亚历山大·洛佩兹一直在指挥亚历山大·洛佩兹的轨道，因为他当然是这样，通过所有的起起伏伏，这意味着基兰发明的大部分传说是他自己的。
Dead right, dead right. And this is what it's a story of. It's a story of a kid who just took something way, way, way, way, way too far in his own mind and has been telling people about it for 10 years since.
死对，死对。这就是这个故事的意义。这是一个关于一个孩子在自己头脑中把事情想得太远、太远，并在十年后一直告诉人们的故事。
Kieran Morris, thank you for coming clean about who you actually are.
基兰·莫里斯，谢谢你坦白你实际上是谁。
It's a pleasure. It's a pleasure. I'm closer to knowing.
这是我的荣幸。这是我的荣幸。我更接近知道了。
That story was adapted from the podcast Pablo Torre Finds Out, which Pablo likes to say is a show about sports, the way Moneyball is a book about baseball. I've been enjoying it. And he just had a big story this week about salary caps and Kawhi Leonard that made national headlines. Thanks also to his producer, Chris Tumminello.
那个故事改编自播客《巴勃罗·托雷找出真相》，巴勃罗喜欢说这是一档体育节目，就像《点球成金》（Moneyball）是一本关于棒球的书一样。我一直在享受它。这周他刚刚有一个关于工资帽和科怀·伦纳德（Kawhi Leonard）的大故事，登上了全国头条。也要感谢他的制作人克里斯·图米内洛（Chris Tumminello）。
Our program was produced by Lilly Sullivan with help from Suzanne Gaber. People who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Audrey Fromson, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mando, Stowe Nelson, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starecheski, Christopher Swetala, and Marisa Robertson-Textor. Our managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. This week, we say goodbye to our office coordinator, Jendayi Bonds. She is off to teach music to kids, which, frankly, is a much more interesting job than the job she had with us. And she gets to use her talents way more in this new job. We will miss her, though.
我们的节目由莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）制作，苏珊·盖伯（Suzanne Gaber）协助。今天节目的制作团队包括Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Audrey Fromson, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mando, Stowe Nelson, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starecheski, Christopher Swetala, and Marisa Robertson-Textor。我们的管理编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的资深编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。这周，我们要告别我们的办公室协调员Jendayi Bonds。她要去教孩子们音乐，说实话，这比她在我们这儿的工作有趣多了。她在新工作中能发挥她的才能。不过我们会想念她的。
Special thanks today to Valerie Caesar, Maryam Alwan, Grant Miner, Carly Schaffer, Ramzi Kassem, Joseph Howley, Jude Taha, Diala Shamas, Shezza Abboushi Dallal, Rosy Fitzgerald, Amber Von Schassen, My Khanh Ngo, Nora Benavidez, Sara Yasin, Ramy Youssef, Lily Saltzberg, Gaia Caramazza, and the filmmakers of The Encampments.
特别感谢Valerie Caesar, Maryam Alwan, Grant Miner, Carly Schaffer, Ramzi Kassem, Joseph Howley, Jude Taha, Diala Shamas, Shezza Abboushi Dallal, Rosy Fitzgerald, Amber Von Schassen, My Khanh Ngo, Nora Benavidez, Sara Yasin, Ramy Youssef, Lily Saltzberg, Gaia Caramazza, 以及《营地》（The Encampments）的制作人。
It has been an entire week since I have mentioned that if you become a This American Life partner, you get ad-free listening, you get a greatest-hits archive right in your podcast feed, and you get access to bonus episodes. There are now dozens of them. Some of them are honestly really kind of wonderful. To check them out, subscribe at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
整整一周没提了，如果你成为《美国生活》的合伙人，你会获得无广告收听，你会直接在播客订阅源中获得一个经典合辑，你还可以获得奖励剧集的访问权限。现在有几十个了。其中一些真的真的很精彩。想看看它们，在thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners订阅。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He got into his first bar fight this week. What did it feel like?
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他这周参加了他的第一次酒吧斗殴。感觉怎么样？
What I felt was as if somebody took a bottle and slammed it onto my head.
我的感觉就像有人拿着瓶子猛击我的头。
I'm Ira Glass back, next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。